[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
date si tu perds quand tu es avec moi de
me planter
cette semaine le sans fil très présenté
par paul islip si vous avez écouté le
podcast avec mark fields vous savez à
quel point les sommets sont importants
pour optimiser nos vies et moshé
qu'activement que c'est amélie reymond
sommeil puis une des meilleures façons
d'améliorer votre sommeil c'est en
changeant votre matelas police est une
compagnie québécoise qui font leur
matelas 100% morial qui livrent avec le
plus grand souci de l'écologie possible
à émettre le matin dans les petites
boîtes pour maximiser les déplacements
même gamme oriali libre avec chasseurs
courrier qu'une compagnie de livraison à
vélo donc si l'écologiste important pour
vous que vous voulez changer votre
matelas c'est la meilleure façon de
fonctionner et nous avons des oreillers
pour qu'on les teste huawei exactement
où j'ai des vieux à rayer un peu poche
puis le on a reçu j'ai reçu les
oreillers policiers que j'essayais qui
je trouve est un peu gros et dur d'abord
mais j'avais pas compris le concept le
principe sont costauds malesherbes dans
le fond fact plus l'ouvrir enlever des
envies des couches fac l'aimais drame à
la hauteur que tu veux donc le cas j'ai
compris ça gémit à la hauteur parfaite
pileux ou se tenir et bien sûr mon
oreille ifac et pallie slip
ouais moi aussi je suis les oreillers
puis honnêtement j'ai hâte de me coucher
à chaud si jamais on vous a pas
convaincu encore de changer vos matelas
6 quelque chose que vous hésitez puis
vous n'êtes pas sûr si vous voulez en
utilisant notre code promo check-out
sans fil de 70 sauver 70 dollars sur
votre commande de mettre le ou si vous
voulez changer juste vous auriez vous
fait sur les codes promo sans filtre 10
lors du check out le lien vers le site
de police lit va être dans la
description du podcast sinon cette
semaine sur le sans filtre nord-est
catherine brunet comédienne
qui joue présentement dans 5e rares du
canada que tu es longtemps avec dans
l'émission le chalet la fameuse émission
trac tv on le connu dans le monde de
charlotte old school a fait beaucoup de
doublage ou centres comme comédienne
très occupés qui est aussi un peu connu
pour lancer des petites pointes et se
moquer parfois des influenceurs donc
c'est quelqu'un qui ont ces bouffées
demandé d'éviter pour avoir cette
discussion le qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qui cloche qu'est ce que ce reproche aux
influences et puis on ne débat dessus
sur ce sujet-là réfléchir les questions
de la pertinence d'influenceurs ce que
c'est bon c'est pas bon dans une société
tous une conversation suspendus en sus
par intéressante où on a réussi à
trouver des terrains d'entente en plus
de l entendre que des terrains d entente
de mésentente
tout à fait
comment ça c'est super intéressant
vraiment si vous écoutez en ce moment
sur youtube abonnez-vous à notre chaîne
commenter la vidéo nous votre opinion
sur la discussion qu'on vient d'avoir
avec catherine sinon si vous écoutez sur
balado laissez-nous un rating de cinq
étoiles ça fait son bout de chemin
ça permet en plus de monde de connaître
le podcast et sinon bon écoute bon
podcast
[Musique]
arrête ça tourne catherine m ces balades
tu es une des personnes comme moi parce
que tu es on demande des fois si nos
vidéos youtube
il commentait des gens qui que vous
invitez mais tout est une des personnes
comme le plus recommandé naïveté à
l'intérieur 2010 à oui je sais je m'en
veux pas trop l'avouer c'est venu un peu
de cas qu'on a commencé à inviter des
gens du web
oui influenceurs entre autres qui est le
monde écrivait je serais vraiment
curieux d'entendre quatre catherine
s'exprimer plus longuement sur qu'est ce
qu'apporte d'influenceurs se chiffonnent
contente parce que souvent les gens à
tort me dise the world que août et
gentille nouvelle qui comme et la guerre
entre eux puisque mon dieu c'est
tellement pour moi faka semaine l'indicé
comme ben oui ça va me faire plaisir
c'est le fun qu'on puisse en parler
aussi
mais en mai un plan plus comme on disait
juste que quand est arrivé ça pourrait
pas mieux tomber
ça va ouvrir ça ouvre la discussion sur
terre plein d'affaires après le père
loin quillard dans un
dans une vidéo qui circule dans un taxi
hier que complètement pété une coche ou
rien et de piété malheureuse il était
marié tu es malheureux d'être dans un
taxi avec aucun moyen de payer sauf une
carte qui décrit dit joe cadeau non
voilà je me disais que c'est quoi staff
à quoi une carte cadeau de la compagnie
de taxis non mais c'est une carte de
crédit vous savez même pas que ça
existait mais c'est une carte de crédit
prépayée taxer genre ça ça donne du
cachet fac lui semble payer à yzeure
reste un risque que des noms mais août
outre ce seuil il l'est qui a pris
ce pays était pas complètement fou avec
une carte cadeau j'ai lancé la situation
et chante
pourquoi pour être pris dans un taxi
quand tu te rends compte que moi ça
m'est déjà arrivé de dire à qui le avoue
prenez pas les cartes c'est ok mais faut
arrêter un guichet péter comme pourquoi
fo n'est pas qu'ils existent pour se
comprendre
c'est comme si nous étions déjà ses
chiens mais en fait moi c'est ce que je
trouvais mais pas drôle un peu de bruit
drôle en même temps mais c'est le fait
que de ce film est comme si ça devenir
un réflexe n'est pas la situation au
lieu d'appeler un ami
ouais c'est sûr c'est comme le premier
réflexe est de dire moi le regarder je
suis pas ni dans cette situation là est
ce que c'est pour faire plier le
monsieur ce que c'est pour documenter
cette affaire le est ce que c'est pour
mettre la pression je sais pourquoi la
pensée qui vient logiquement pas de se
gâter monsieur je vous expose voici que
la station puisse qui est un peu bizarre
puisque blizzard de filmer quelqu'un qui
leur demandait une autre mais c'est pas
la seule à feinter dans le sens que là
c'est une situation particulière puisque
ça et puis quelqu'un d'autre mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est souvent t
il y avait il y en a qui se filme
pendant qu'ils regardent des films qui
pleure il y en a qui y tic telle espèce
d'affaires de parler à la caméra salut
tout le monde
aujourd'hui ben je parle de quelque
chose comme si c'était un ami des facs y
ait quelque chose de très intéressant là
dedans aussi dans cette affaire le de se
confier à du monde que tu connais pas
parce que c'est ton métier mais je pense
que lui c'est un peu comme ça a été son
réflexe parce que c'est ce que sa vie
soit pas aussi au sein d'une espèce de
deuxième nature le dialecte quelque
chose et puis on lui a tout de moi
j'allais des fauchés dans l'autobus
comme à la lumière et belges soit une
super belle plc empreinte forte ici
comme mais pourquoi je fais ça pour que
je suis fière podor puis je dois à ma
vie ouais ouais mais il ya
définitivement questionnement petit moi
je les véhicules de première main
derrière mais l'espèce de
questionnements de me dire ok si je veux
rester
dans cet univers le faut que je sois
actifs pour être actif faut que ça
devienne comme un réflexe que j'ai si je
veux qu'ils sont un réflexe je peux pas
juste mes films et moi qui marchent dans
la rue faut que ce soit pendant que je
fais des enfants vous intéresser les
gens et là j'arrive à un moment où est
ce que je fais une affaire mais qu'ils
s'entendent pas de sortir mon cellulaire
le montrer mais ma n'était pas justement
tu es comme berne même temps je dois te
fais occupation double fac et quelque
chose dans l'oeil du public qui
m'intéressait des jeux dans cette espèce
d'affaires le est en tout cas ça
s'appelle des recettes d'une manière ou
d'une autre de vivre en pis après tématé
maintenant cette personne là c'est un
influenceur le kiki dans le public aussi
même année c'est ça c'est ça doit être
tanins d'avoir des comptes arrange en
remettant un spectable envie de dire
ouais notre coupe stanley dit c'est
comme tu deviens un poème à l'italienne
ni par sa femme bun moi j'ai arrêté de
la fin
ok ok ouais moi j'ai comme le monde suit
activement nous checker mais parce que
moi j'ai arrêté de la forte n'importe
qui me suit j'en ai sûrement rendu
compte le jeu fait plus vraiment ce
juste parce que c'était vraiment pas
naturel ça n'est jamais devenu trop
petit pour comprendre paix au boudoir à
ce qu'on a dans son affaire qui s'est
passé pour reprendre son histoire c'est
que j'aurai justement comme disait
tantôt cas qui dit c'est quoi mes
options loge son investiture est de
filmer appelle un ami il va venir te
dépanner et plusieurs officiers vraiment
beaucoup d'options puis celle que tu es
en train de fret n'est clairement pas
une bonne option
c'est un énorme manque de jugement puis
manque de classe aussi j'ai l'impression
en vraiment un monsieur qui fait juste
son travail mais je pense qu'il y en a
plus il y pensait pas mal c'est sale
affaire c'est que tu aimais tant je
pense à lézan mme nadeau aussi entre
autres kilani parti a fait une crise de
panique dans un événement public qui
son premier réflexe a été de se filmer
en train de lui arrive d'être en attaque
de paniers de dire aux gens qu'ils
avaient une attaque de panique puis ça
moi même en regardant ce que j'ai fait à
mon dieu si je fais moi même une attaque
de panique non sans fierté c'est super
de troublant de voir quelqu'un dans
cette situation le mot si j'en fais des
crises de panique si paul von pas en
doute pas tout il c'est vrai que ça
puisse sensibiliser mettons agir la
sopie même et je me dis qu'est ce qui
fait que c'est ton premier réflexe mais
je trouve que ça doit être anxiogène de
sentir la pression de tout le temps ce
film et je ça revient un peu assommés je
pense que c'est jamais pour mme alphabet
jamais se dire je vois faire un show ce
post c'est juste que ça devient comme
une seconde nature bien un réconfort
c'est maintenant mon cas je fais une
attaque de panique la sphère qui me
réconforte c'est pas ça à des cornichons
frites et ouais mais je médite accueil
c'est comme un jeu sais pas c'est ça qui
me fascine en fait de ce thème on
imagine quand certaines personnes je
commence et c'est ce qu'ils allaient
recevoir les commentaires de gens
quitter ça va bien aller à nantes avec
toi qui as toutes ses dents ça suppose
une photo je veux pas que les gens
soient comme si l'aise là le support de
jam qui nous qui nous suivent qui nous
suivent de loin même s'ils sont loin ça
reste quand même des passes quand même
un support qui est intéressant à voir
surtout c'est pour les bonnes raisons
exactes battisti mais c'est que en fait
je pense qu'il ya personne qui fait pour
les mauvaises raisons le thé jeudi même
si tu le fais juste pour être connu ce
une raison pour une mauvaise non mais je
pense quand même que ça peut engendrer
du mal art et très probablement qui
acquiesce à soit pas chez eux pour les
personnes que pour les gens qui les
suivent qui mettront les jeunes je
supporte parle pour 1m anorexie boulimie
québec qui depuis quelques années avec
la montée fulgurante est à g
lien si pire trouve alimentation sont
développés parce que avant tu mets ton
se comparer aux mannequins aux actifs
liquides et puis le jeu par le préfet
mais pour les gosses il mais aujourd'hui
c'est comme l'espèce de de désir de
genre réalité d'authenticité loties
comme voici ma vraie vie
voici mon vrai corps voici mon vrai mon
ma vraie chaîne moi ma vraie tpiy fait
que comme une espèce d'affaires de
hockey sauvegarde sa longueur de journée
pas moins livré à faire ce post suffit
pas que ça crée des complexes encore
plus grand pas que même quand c'est pour
bien faire c'est le bol y poser des vis
déjà c'est vrai que c'est important
sauf que ça y'a des double tranchant
tout et surtout quand on apprend qu'en
bout de ligne
cette intensité l'ol possède anti que ce
que ça arrive au site
c'est sans doute tabou c'est authentique
authentique mais manny je trouve que
c'est galvaudé comme on le jeudi
l'authenticité ou quand les gens
maintenant dix mois la fois que j'ai
recherché quelqu'un c'est de
l'authenticité moi je suis quelqu'un
d'authentiqué
mais c'est que le contrat serait
vraiment wac déjà c'est bizarre qu'on me
on met autant d'emphase sur
l'authenticité logiquement tout le monde
est authentique
il ya quelques personnes peut-être qu'on
pourrait dire qu'ils sont hypocrites ou
pas camani l'otan d'ici jusqu'au mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est quoi
je pense que ce mot là cette expression
la plus que je le vois plus comme une
expression comme un mot le être
authentique à ce moment ci mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu un c'est
un peu un non-sens de d'utiliser cette
expression là dans un contexte où est ce
que il ya une mise en scène est
nécessaire toujours parce que même
admettons que je prends mon cela que
j'estime à et le le tofu aux arachides
quel jeune frère est écoeurant c'est pas
moi qui est authentique lé monde et
authentique c'est moi qui mange le teuff
aux arachides qui fait masse 6 mais
c'est toi qui tenteraient de faire caca
la danse
je sais pas il ya de quoi de mais c'est
comme si moi je disais je suis
comédienne mais tous mes rôles sont
authentiques team je suis vraiment
authentique comme comédienne c'est un
non sens que j'ai l'impression que yoyo
du monde qui eux
justement pour reprendre l'exemple de
légende qui je trouve qui s'est
construit une espèce de de following
ultra intéressés par l dispenserait
prendre vraiment de ce qui montre sur
ces réseaux sociaux vraiment de quoi de
positif pour pour pour les personnes qui
la suivent
j'ai l'impression que ça le jeu
réfléchir avant que j'y pense encore au
quotidien mais j'ai l'impression que
cela un rôle positif dans la société qui
avait des gens qui soient qui a et ce
rôle j'ai l'impression que c'est encore
nouveau encore quelque chose qu'on
ignore qu on connaît très mal mais j'ai
l'impression que sur le long terme
certaines personnes peuvent pas en train
de dire les gens qui font juste vendre
des trucs comme des panneaux
publicitaires mais j'ai l'impression de
certaines personnes ont un rôle à jouer
dans l'éducation de la société parce que
les réseaux sociaux sont là qu'on le
veuille ou non
maintenant comment on s'assure que les
gens je te demande les enfants qui ont
hissé leur dans leurs mains à 10 ans
sont capables d'avoir des exemples
positifs t mais si c'est sûr qu'après
qu'est-ce qui est un exemple vous n'êtes
pas juste 10 ans on parle de plein
d'affaires de pleinement parce que
maintenant tout le monde veut son sa
tribune sont dit si souvent on dit c'est
ouais c'est un exemple positif un
exemple aussi mais c'est quoi un exemple
dans son ski siens exemple possible de
dans son opinion
ok mais tu ans a dépeint après c'est que
y'a personne qui a la science infuse la
marque de thé dansant non mais c'est
vrai at il eu des liens avec des fois je
trouve que la ligne est mince entre est
ce que c'est un bon exemple où ça
qu'est-ce que ça démontre quelqu'un qui
vit devant son téléphone
qui donne son opinion sur têt certains
sujets comme piqué les jeunes surtout
mettant de 14 à 18 boivent leur parole
comme de l'eau qui lâche l'école puis
qu'ils disent ben moi c'est ce que je
vais faire je vois parler abondamment
dans mon salon et en effet moi je pense
qu'il ya plein plein plein de bonnes
choses qui vont sortir d'internet mettez
en général et c'est juste qu'il ya des
fois je trouve que ces evs et le ti
comme bien d affaire justement le lait
quand on parle de chirurgie quand on
parle de sexe quand on parle de thé de
sujets que
quand tu es à 14 15 16 c'est imputé cet
te forger une opinion
une personnalité et que on passe
tellement de temps sur notre téléphone
puis les jeunes aussi le sait pas
différent et moi je me rappelle je
finissais l'école j'allais sur le média
changé mais les habitudes pauvresse qui
je me dis moi mettons à 14 ans avoir eu
ces gens là comme exemple puis jeudi
gens là mais je dire je m'inclus là
dedans aussi où a germé et il ya quelque
chose qui est un peu qu'ils aient pas la
réalité puisque même si oui des fois
mettons je regarde gloria belge qui
quitteraient lgbt qi pita blanc et c'est
super ça c'est génial qu'on puisse
parler de ces sujets là puis qu'on
puisse avoir
mais c'est juste qu'il faut je pense
prendre tout un petit peu plus à la
légère
on sait ce que je trouve ce qu'elle veut
si comme devenu super sérieux
pis là on peut aimer ton mot je sais le
gym mon personnage d'influenceurs je me
faire avancer les gens c'est de
l'intimidation plus comme elle sait on
au rire un peu le aussi de tout seul
parce que je fais aussi on peut plus
enrayer puissions peut pas dire bon moi
c'est cette capsule par exemple de telle
influence heures je trouve ça aberrant
et un peu comme si comme ce qui est
arrivé avec pays où il ya plein de gens
qui en fait d'un voyant dans son pote
mon sens mais y'en a plein d'enfants
domaine sur internet c'est juste que
l'on dirait que ça fait du bien à tout
le monde de bâches et collectivement 1
éruption une personne c'est alors que
y'en a plein d vidéo horrible puis un
peu gênant pitié avec des opinions qui
ont pas de maudit bon sens pis folk
avant de répondre à ce sens que ça soit
ps comme l'intimidation mais que cette
cession est une kia une discussion mais
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup
d'influenceurs qui n'ont pas le goût de
la voir cette chienlit psicom qu'iga moi
je fais ce que je veux le képi comme
j'enfile mon opinion fait que george est
vraiment un endroit plus calme
oui il foule sauf que moi je dois te
dire que j'aime pas ce puits que ça fait
rire ou que sous ce superficielle par me
manque mais toi tu as le droit de dire
aussi que mon métier c'est là dans la
boue et je m'en fous nous six heures
c'est que je pense qu'ils manquent de
funcom perdre une fan d'internet
ouais c'est du sérieux je prouverai je
comprends
c'est vraiment des réflexions vraiment
dans l'air du temps
pepy secteur de mettre le doigt sur
quelque chose puis bon si je pense
souvent je suis obsédé avec sa femme où
est-ce que ça s'en va c'est quoi lasser
koala est ce que on est juste dans une
transition vers quelque chose d'autre
ce que c est ce qu on va passablement
atteindre un moment où est ce qui va
avoir plus de règles plus de dix heures
en même temps ça enlèverait un petit peu
la patente sans les vrais de l'intérêt
du truc mais c'est complet que je crois
qu une des raisons pourquoi c'est devenu
plus sérieux c'est que c'est devenu une
job c'est une job littéralement ou est
ce que par exemple quelqu'un qui vend un
produit je vais me prendre moi comme
exemple parce que je les fais souvent
des bains pour nous balader sous les
courses qui dit
pour que je me mette en scène pour faire
passer un certain message
même si c'est pas une extension très
différente de moi le jeu met en scène
pour faire passer un message que
quelqu'un me dit de faire passer il faut
que j'essaie d'avoir des statistiques
sont à la hauteur du prix que pour
lequel je payais pour faire de la fin
avec la insight
ils m'ont dit je vais mourir les accords
non mais après je te laisse venir mais
ça c'est fou quand même parce que je
dire tu aimais tant cette compagnie là
que c'est correct parce qu'on le fait
mouche si je lis déjà fait le gers les
produits frais comme hier les produits
comme si le fun des fois aussi comme je
comprends qu enseigner travail le thé
mais mettons sigean l'est ici coop
tellement mettons le prix de leur pub de
leur contrainte woippy 10 wall e fax et
comme ton affaire qui met en scène
depuis le temps parle de toi comme l'air
triste
oui mais dont le juge ait pas donné un
le meilleur exemple parce qu'ils nous
baladent j'adore mairie ça parce que je
cours de toute façon parce que tout ce
qui me demande de faire je le fais toute
façon pis je courais que c'est celui-là
anyway de s'y fixer
c'est vraiment mais mettons un
shampooing pour les ch'tis ou est-ce que
mais ce que j'utiliserai shampoing là je
sais pas si je suis rassuré un point
lors de ses mails il faut que je fasse
comme si tu es le meilleur shampoing
j'utilise ma vie de cépie peas et c'est
cet enjeu sauf qu'après ses excuses moi
je vais finir céder là c'est pour
revenir sur sur la raison pour laquelle
je pense est devenu sérieux c'est
qu'après ce mois ci à quelqu'un qui me
cale sur seul temps fort un peu chier
parce que c'est quand même c'est un peu
ma job pis si tu comprends pas que cet
aspect là c'est comme si je t'écoute est
la télé puis en deux dans une enseigne
publicitaire tu voyais guillaume lemay
thivierge qui relance à youndé pas
encore les guillaume lemay thivierge you
did you go away comédie y mettons les
chanteurs céline dion le comédien on ne
rit d'elle ou bye bye comme une fonderie
guy a lepage est normal quand on est
dans l'oeil du public non ce sens ce
métier là qu'on rit toi ça c'est sûr que
quand tu deviens non c'est que l'homme à
fond la même chose c'est la même chose
aux échanges aux expériences et quand tu
vois la pub derbala sans cesse que la
fille a joué sa douche shampoing tout le
sexe une actrice qui est payé pour être
l'hôte russie qui est ici tout se vendre
la fin les influenceurs défaut les pubs
sont plus camoufler peut-être où ça
passe à la nature et à bonne source de
produits halal à naples c'est comme un
espèce de peu par la banque mais là
maintenant et un choix de m mais
n'empêche que c'est comme en ton nom
personnel tpo comme un personnage et
exane pub qui vend quelque chose sauf
que si tu prends la décision de vendre
ce produit là de faire ses choix de vie
le kick qui te vient ton métier est
fondation dans le sens qu évidemment
mettre en joue dans l le chalet le thé
j'assume que les gens fassent comme à
chalais siwak genre les jeunes dans un
chantier comme jeu sam c'est normal que
qui a des gens qui aiment pas seule
puisqu'elle va toujours avoir des gens
que pour rire ou pour se moquer ou
pourrait faire des jokes là dessus ou
pourrait même et je pense que en tant
qu' influenceurs comme tu dis c'est en
duo mais type si c'est vrai c'est
sérieux je le conçois tu aimais me
rappelle plus qui récemment écrit jean
ray c'est difficile comme métier il faut
qu'on pense des vidéos ou qu'on fasse
nos recherches vous qu'on fasse des pubs
comme mais c'est ta job
moi honnêtement je suis loin d'être
celui qui est le plus sollicité mais
honnêtement quelqu'un qui met plus que
35 heures dans ce seul je sais pas
comment tu fais pour gérer ses affaires
si j'ose dire si je comprends pas je
comprends pas comment tu peux passer
plus que 35 ans même si tu veux faire un
post à chaque jour avec des historiques
toi tu comprends pas comment je peux
mettre plus que 35 heures dans ce qu'on
a entendu à la scam a bloqué 35 ans ben
si tu enlèves tout ce qui est
procrastination police ont fuit depuis
répondre aux commentaires
non c'est ce qui est offert un pot ça
doit prendre quinze minutes et aussi
éditer la couleur de leurs photos cru
que ça peut leur prendre le thé comme
puis en fait c'est que si c'est ta job
mais 70 ans maintenant mais c'est ça mon
point le ce que je te disais que le 35
heures c'est admettons que tu dépasses
jeudi ya du monde qui qui font leur job
à tout les jours 50 heures de travail
autonome fait exact c'est une job c'est
un travail c'est le travail que j'ai
choisi de prendre si le temps que ça
prend exact c'est normal que des gens
qui aiment possible c'est normal que des
gens qui aient dix opinions là dessus
plus énorme tout seuil normal
expekt com et pour trouver le fun un peu
puis des dit le dicton j'ai tendance à
être d'accord quelqu'un qu'il fait bien
ca d'amour donné le mot iphone à l'avant
il von ah l'amour s'en câlisse fait que
de ma pub
l'autre jour il est à la toilette
larcher la pire cas ici c'est celle mes
amis sociaux sans story puis le père
s'est cabré si on était on était au
chalet tu la gagnes nos débats lyon
c'était loin chalet bleu lui est
choquant vêtements mais ça va tout leur
plaisent ils sachent ou appeler le tapir
qualifie comme la story fini sauf que le
lendemain matin s'est réveillé puis au
putsch et portugaise en scène fait que
l'oeil avant il faisait unboxing
méconnaît le boxing avec les produits ti
t'écoute c'est toute la chaîne history
ces genres le perdre gros
mr obs pilar story d'après cnbc si on
paye pour ça mais quand même ça décrit
bien ouais c'est clair a dit maintenant
c'est drôle c'est insisté il y en a qui
le font
drôle encore pis mon fils dit très épuré
maintenant petit mais toi tu penses que
tu voulais écrire ma maîtrise métissé
l'eau qu'il est je vais pas commencer à
mettre son nom face à face comme de
filmer le procès à l'hôtel mandarin dit
cette phrase le smac comme la page
blanche non mais c'est vraiment comme la
page blanche mais tu aurais pas le goût
de ces méthodes et fois des genres pop
de concentrer là dessus puis est ce que
comme les réseaux sociaux ça a pris pour
toi le métier mais françoise a pris pour
toi comme cette proportion lors
d'interviews tu dis moi toute ma vie je
veux faire ça puisse choquer crédit non
non non non non non non le on travaille
activement justement sur le podcast sur
un autre projet qui volent optimalement
- me permette de disparaître comme seul
objectif derrière toute la pâte ans
disparue cite les énormes c'est un peu
ça c'est d'utiliser comme le tremplin
que j'ai eue pour faire les avoirs que
je réponds eu la chance de faire mes
deux tranquillement pas vite juste que
tu as à me suivre sur instagram juste si
tu veux voir un selphy ou des fois un
petit bien m de signes de qu'est ce que
je fais mais ce repos ce vraiment pas ça
m'a permis ça nous a permis de partir
mais affectée si c'est ça c'est de
partir de là puis d'utiliser cette
tribune là mais c'est passé
objectivement punk l'écriture a encore
une place le sait sur qui j'ai beaucoup
de choses dans ma vie qui fonctionne ici
de m'asseoir vraiment que décrire le ti
créatif et ségou non exercés sac ou de
loin c'est tout le temps mais temps
après je sais pas s'ils s'y est aussi
salutaire la même chose le pont celson
puis faut que tu répondes papa tu peux
pas juste la mer le bac bernard pendant
quatre 4 heures le sait mais après c'est
que j'ai une coupe de hymer le team et
genre sinon non jusqu'à pas bon quand
même au carlyle legault la crise
instagram ya quelques jours je m'en suis
même pas rendu compte
et oui j'allais tout en main puis chèque
le pij
mais si je peux m'en passer pendant les
capable complètement et parce que moi je
peux ma job ou sans ce système - mettant
je le fais vraiment par plaisait puis
par am diverti au maximum le ti les
réseaux sociaux pis mais ce qui est
spécial secteur following était
comparable à justement les français qui
fait se sa ville
mettez tout wolf l'utiliser tout tu le
fais mais j'ai toujours ce coin sens que
si je pense des photos mais pour moi les
réseaux sociaux et a toujours été comme
une manière de m'exprimer
le thème étant dans le temps de facebook
ça fonctionnait encore il mettait en
trop mais facebook pour moi maintenant
c'est plus comme une question que mes
amis du statut des 10 de s'échanger des
opinions mais instagram et ont pour moi
c'est une lieu de gens repartent âge
d'or 2d aussi quand même temps puis en
tant que comédienne mais était aussi
pour les jeunes
je pense que ça vient avec un peu aussi
cela dit moi j'ai des amis comédiens
je pense à mon amie laurence leboeuf
entre autres à la police un grain masse
en fou et elle est top besoins en soins
dans notre métier moi je pense que vu
qu'on a grandi avec ce belge poignée de
dents puis j'ai du fun puis justement le
reste était pas comédienne dont juste
pour tes amis pour tes preuves
sensiblement la même chose mais oui
parce que souvent quand je fais un post
je pense à mes amis puis je faire rire
mes amis puis je veux je veux qu'il
trouve que mon enquête j'ai beau puis tu
sais comme l'agglo oui des fois je faire
des pauses de pub mettant pour les
maisons le chalet où je m'apprêtais
parce que j'y tiens puisque sam james
hook et leigh jan wald et cause pour une
corde exactement cela dit j'aime est en
moi je je je crucifix pas genre la pub
sur les réseaux du pacot contre se
mettant moi qui ai bien dit le genre
arrivent au québec qui me disait on
donne genre une cargaison avis il fait
c'est nous la promo objets comme mais
beaucoup croient en plus aux produits
avec ghani sme en fait pdp top tapis
parce que ça c'est important de le faire
puis on a une tribune fictifs on
l'utilisé puis c'est cool de pouvoir le
faire
taquet non je peux contre seppi oui je
le fais des fois parce qu'il est prêt
mettant comme les friperies en ligne une
friperie cas par an sur laquelle
j'achète tout temps mais vêtements puis
juste et je suis devenu comme un petit
chemin café puis tout seul fan de se
faire de la pub parce que ça me tient
sous seule femme
tant qu'à avoir une tribune je veux
l'utiliser pour le challenge cessé de
faire la part des choses mais tu peux te
permettre de le faire
sitôt à autre chose de colin jordan
active de recettes avec ma blonde
piscine ça nous permet de vivre à partir
de l'autre dépend pas des revenus juste
basée sur les publicités sur instagram
fait que ça permet d'attaquer mais seuls
golfeurs s'ajoutent chose ça m'intéresse
parce que je le fasse je fais alors que
si c'est juste que tu fais ce que tu
fais moins de luz un peu le pendant
exact comme une vague de bouchons
s'étaient approchés sur une bonne vague
qu'est-ce qui est un contrat extrêmement
payant mais c'est sûr mais c'est ça
c'est sûr que c'est super payante et
puis maintenant moi je le vois en plus
les gens m'approchent maintenant
directement puissants comme on le sait
que tu fais pas ça mais moyenne
peut-être faut qu'on travaille fort pour
trouver un terrain d'entente les ti
commun parce que je suppose que ma job
puis je m'en fous moi de recevoir des
chaussées comme je veux je veux je m'en
fous mais comme tu dis c'est quand c'est
tombé si bas tu t'en fous tu dis il faut
que tu assumes que l'état fasse qui
représente un produit dit ce qui est fou
c'est qu'elle me tende et fois les
compagnies m'approche puissants comme à
et on paye mettant 2000 pièces pour
faire un pas aux puces comme mais c'est
parce que si je faisais une pub en tant
que comédienne je serai payé même plus
que ça fait pourquoi je prendrais elle
sur mes épaules la responsabilité de
vous faire une pub cheap
alors qui est juge peut choquer tout
c'est comme un peu genre mélange entre
une impression que telle autre part est
ton amie laurence leboeuf qui pour
l'instant g et sympathique avec le temps
ça va devenir inévitable puisque amende
ni ces espèces de se faire deux mondes
le ils vont se croiser parce que c'est
peut-être que peut-être qu'à être world
heroes parce que 220 2000 la bonne
istres instagram et c'est aussi et la
popularité ati le monde des vols drapés
dans leur film parce qu'il pleure ou
simplement parce qu'il est bon petit
l'impression qu'à man et sa voix est
inévitable piqué ou si le web la
télévision ça va c'est le maintenant et
c'est de lier des séries web c'est tout
se mélange on voit des gens qui ont
commencé sur les réseaux sociaux sur
youtube patients de traverser geste vers
ceux affectés peut-être qu'avec le temps
ça va devenir un grand meeting potes
j'espère que non j'ai pas feutrés ça me
fait pas dans le sens que je trouve que
parce qu'ils étaient
c'est pas que genre chaque personne fait
son métier c'est tout est au contraire
le savons tous le monde peut essayer des
choses moi même des fois je fais des
affaires que je me dis pas encore de des
communes au seul point
c'est plus que moi j'ai l'impression que
si un producteur m'engage parce que j
122 wafers pour le projet dans laquelle
joue vouloir jouer si je pense que l'or
ouais pile à la télé le cinéma la
musique le chant lll l'écriture je pense
que quelque chose là dedans qui fait
pour raconter une histoire puis toucher
les gens au delà de la réalité il le
tient je pense que williams année ça se
mélange laisser jouer comme tu dis pas
ça c'est correct le thillay manil toutes
vos données du web
anyone là où j'ai un problème si si
vraiment on commence à engager les gens
juste parce qu'ils ont dû forme humide
il ya plus rien de sa critique
et toi au théâtre ça va être ça va être
bon qu'ils peuvent vendre des billets
exact c'est sa fille sage m6 qui jouait
hamlet
[Rires]
c'est normal dans chaque milieu si on
est comme des enfants qui sont sacrées
pour nous mettons au théâtre qu'en
langage du monde qui a aidé des acteurs
mettant comme moi qui ont peu fait
d'école ouais mais tant que j'avais un
rôle au tnm ce que du monde qui dirait
ben c'est sympa ce que l'état fait de la
télé l'école après je comprendrais très
aussi quand même y ait des affaires qui
je sais pas si c'est un débat vraiment
qui comme un fini pour moi le de la
question c'est est ce que c'est vrai que
tu t'es choisi parce que les populaires
ou parce qu'ils te trouve bon pit et
populaire
son seul talent fait avant tout par ses
clans je pense que oui mais sauf qu'ils
étaient clairement ce pot sol fait que
je faisais
et en effet je pense que tu vas voir le
choix d'embarquer dans game ou ne pas
embarquer dans game et puis si tu
embarques pas d'un gameplay qui
travaillent pas à cause de sa belle
c'est ça parce que j'ai l'impression
mettons que des jeux donner l'exemple de
claude legault et ceux qui n'ont rien à
rien à crisser laitiers mais j'ai
l'impression que il y en aurait plus
vraiment de personnes qui vont être
capables
je projette dans pas si longtemps que
souhaité j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vantent eu elle-même va falloir
entretenir sur parce que c'est eux qui
ont commencé leur carrière de cette
façon là puisque ceux qui peuvent la
continuer comme ça mais j'ai vraiment
l'impression que l'on en est ils vont en
espèces de deux mecs le thé mais y en a
cela dit c'est qu'il y en a toujours eu
et émettons moi je pense souvent à andy
warhol qui a dit dans le futur chaque
personne à voir son cinq minutes de
gloire parce que ce soit d'autre je
connaissais la part de 12 membres mais
qui connaissait la pop culture qui était
extrêmement bien écrit la lettre la pop
comme on la connaît un printemps qui
avait vu je pense dans le potentiel de
l'humanité des jeunes les années 60-70
que les gens trippé sur le voyeurisme
genre l'authenticité justement fait qui
regarde ma maison regarde mon chez nous
je veux te parler de mon couple le temps
les mama fausse couche et comme il y
avait vu ce parce que déjà dans les
années 70 il y avait cette affaire le
temps barque avec les paparazzi se
donner des entrevues
tu te confier il y avait des entrevues
des gens qui venaient chez vous ça a
toujours existé chaque mois je pense
qu'il ya quand même des gens qui vont
résister à cette affaire le métier
mettons c'est quoi résister mois sur les
réseaux plus que sur gazon c'est quoi
manille moi je pense que des gens qui
embarqueront pas là dedans puis ça va
être bien correct où je sais pour mes
tops et 13 ans j'ai aucune idée
daniel touch qui est un humoriste
américain roman controversé faisant un
gag et tuer tout le monde sont quinze
minutes de gloire il dit mais moi c'est
25,1 pour moi c'est zéro pour toi pour
tous moyens
rien sur l'humanité mais non parce que
maintenant des potes et qui peut faire
une immense connerie ouais on le voit le
web sur facebook les vidéos qu'ils
deviennent viros et des vidéos déjà une
fille ses deux enfants dans le char qui
parle du service chez tim hortons pillet
ça devient virale une fille qui reçut un
masque de tri backup qu'il mes petites
recettes dans drôle d'aller vu aussi que
ces grandes idéologies mais temps mais
elles étaient devenues maintenant fait
une carrière avec ça je peux faire une
coupe d'un petit bout de là dessus
maintenant je sais pas bien le russe en
cinq minutes mais c'est ça qui me fait
peur c'est quand même année
n'importe quel coucou peut faire
n'importe quelle connerie qui on va
faire aïe super drôle où elle est super
cool c'est picasso c'est un danger ce
csc temps réel danger on en parlait
justement james hill des jackpots ce
genre de gaulle c'est qui qui conduit
divertissant mais est-ce que ça
participe au bien commun de la société
jean loup metton en dessous qui
justement des défis difficiles des
maillots de bain pendant une demi heure
si je dirais aussi que pitié je veu
diret occupation double c'est entre
autres une des affaires qui maintenant
et c'est quasiment comme un showcase de
personnalités connues le ténor jean
skinny vous ça a été comme un test
c'est un peu une surprise sauf que là
j'ai l'impression que maintenant
n'importe qui qui va être connus qui va
voir un show de reno qui va avoir un
show des jeux c'est paul qui veut
verrouiller les fadas c'est exactement
ça mais on dirait que c'est comme c'est
mon obsession c'est l'audition
ça peut être dangereux parce que
évidemment accès
quand tu regardes ce genre de show là tu
t'attaches je veux pas tu es moi j'adore
ça j'écoute et puis je trouve ça super
même année aussi et où la limite de on
va donner un show à quelqu'un parce
qu'il était drôle dans l'émission tc
comme pigeonneaux a fait 20 ans que je
suis ici puis on parle peu c'est faux et
je vais après tout personne qui m'a
donné un show grave les épaules puis
mais je dirais quand on en a vu des pays
moins stables émotionnellement
il faut de très sales d'un piano pour
qui l'expérience les foules bénéfique
piste de l'oeil après la farine a doté
sa libairie scandale ici c'est triste
sévrier le détail de ce que l'on com -
far west puisqu'ils seront pas données
de produits parce qu'ils sont éliminés
et puis ceux des fois que moi dans le
fond c'est parce que je ne sais pas
c'est vrai j'avais pas pensé à ça oui
est ce qu'on peut faire le parallèle
entre temps maintenant il ya le feedback
automatique en sortant les télé réalité
qui est instagram effectivement le
feedback automatique qui a quelqu'un qui
décide que tu fasses un show qui a
quelqu'un qui veuille de signer pour un
album comme liszt année où elle est
verte est un fil d'acier avant de
rebrancher mais je tenais l'examen
mustier feedback automatique qui est
instagram est ce qu'on peut faire le
parallèle en disant que c'est comme une
espèce du zina personnalités célèbres
avec genre star academy qui finalement
une usine à artistes une usine à
chanteur mais quand tu sors de leucate
sortie de star académie
tu avais pas justement le feedback
automatique très pâle espèce de garantie
que ça valait la peine dit mme en tant
que demi ça se peut que ça valait juste
pas appel mais le cancer' d'eau douce et
que un minimum de quelque chose de
tangible qui est le résultat de ton
expérience et jamais pour en bowling
cb c'est vrai c'est complètement semer
mais je me rappelle aussi à l'époque de
star académie ya plein chanteur qui
m'aiment encore pour la boîte il ya
plein chanteurs qui sont comme moi je
crie jamais c'est parce que ses ventes
sont un homme qui est cité comme des is
you et henin qui est on peut voir la
même chose qui me passionne sommes par
contre par contre c'est ça le problème
que j'ai avec ce discours là de dire ça
c'est la voie facile et cambrai c'est la
voie facile vos résolutions mettons pour
la voile
c'était la blonde homme a fait de la
voile vos auditions mais non est la
droite soit choisi après ça est soit
intéressant pour le public à la voix
d'après souvient mesure que c'est la
voie facile ces occupations de l'isf
rien que c'est une fois c'est terminé
le vrai travail commence tout cuit dans
le bec critique sa star academy la voix
ou même occupation double qui choisit à
ce parce que des marques d'une
quelconque façon dans quelque chose même
occupation des captations toxiques à la
base n'est pas choisie pour incarner
john a un talent mais te sois titeux
probablement les talents de deux ans de
communication de stx et peugeot annonce
il fallait sont choisis parce qu'ils ont
quelque chose de spécial ouais c'est
quoi c'est cela à quantifier leurs
extracteurs des genres quelque chose il
ya quelque chose avec le après sud fait
se met en sorte après un esprit son
esprit entrepreneur ou un esprit de tri
de quelqu'un qui parle des projets qui
travaillent sont à faire pour rester là
parce qu'il est tellement monde qui
veulent être le cas mais si celui ci
s'est passé parce que ce souci je me dis
pourquoi il ya autant nom qui veulent
être laissé seul c'est ça la concerne
pas de sa femme ait dit ou tu vas être
en fait quand tu ailles kg 1
tu vas t'y mets ton comme renault
il y avait un métier il y avait une
carrière mais il voulait à être connu
c'est le rêve de beaucoup de personnes
je comprends mais pourquoi
ouais c'est ça qui me fascine en fait
aussi chaud est ce une bonne second
questionnaire sélectionnant que ces
mêmes d'attenté nous ôtons balit et nous
on se parle avant si je disais que je
souhaiterais pour peut-être avoir quoi
35 mille abonnés puis c'était vraiment
pour cela la raison pour laquelle j
allais parce qu'on savait pas c'est quoi
ça allait donner même s'ils pensaient
ouais mais on savait que ça allait être
eu un résultat maintenant je t'ai pas
prêt à dire que ça allait être positif
c'est quand je participe aux 10
ariègeois 135 mille abonnés on estimait
que j'allais avoir 35 de la bonne et
maintenant qu'est-ce que ça me faisait
ça me laisse alignement petit je te
connais assez pour savoir que la réelle
raison principale pour laquelle tu
allais le thé pour vivre une aventure
[Musique]
une partie de journalistes condom est
juste de dire je vis quelque chose qui
existe politiquement ni mortel zidi
piqué mais j'aurais envie que ce type ça
vaut mais y avait zéro la pensée de
vouloir l' ce qui arrivait après puis
puis l'eau maintenant j'ai l'impression
que ça a été perverti par ce fo vjepa le
savoir non plus vous étiez victime étant
j'étais quand même dire je vais
peut-être avoir 35 mille fameuse maison
moi je suis un des jeux qui mais je me
disais c'est peut-être une affaire de
dégénérer en béton c'était 1-1
commentaires parmi tant d'autres de ce
que je faisais était sec et qu'est-ce
qui est qu'est ce que je dois faire
après l'été puis on essaie de prévoir
mais finalement jamais prévoir qu'est ce
qui va se passer mais affectée si
c'était un une des attentes qu'on avait
qui était pas nécessaire ming était
quand même je suis présente pas si sûr
mais ça reste que moi j'y crois pas que
c'est easy ou et peut-être que par la
team et ankama nous valons de fait la
voie d'allah ni que suivi peut-être que
c'était easy oui un peu on lui fout de
contrôle chanteur plein d'appels faut
quand même tu fasses 550 chopard paradis
je savais la voix le stress qui est
simple et mettons si effectivement on
veut en effet maintenant plus que 6e
mais après ce type qui fait la voix qui
durent rihanna se comptent sur les
doigts d'une main et iquique super belle
carrière qui a fait la voix qui ça reste
tellement facteurs premièrement qu'à
d'étaler leur était super thé était
dessus avait une proposition artistique
était dessus assez solide et est rendu
lui aussi parce qu'il y en a qui vont
qui sont bons mais lyon peut encore sont
pas encore sur leur exclusion pas encore
le choses-là show spécial ces méthodes
des matériaux et le bosquet ou des
forêts cardin qui vont le lion des jeux
se solde aussi ont atteint 100 à 20 plus
beaux qu'on y vont le montrer la vie de
batterie leur affaire aurait sûrement
s'arrêter plus long mais ce serait
rendre l'action réseau qu'un doute puis
de montrer ça pour qui ça a marché dès
nous mettons gpo d'éclopés le gag ou des
flips bras qu il serait allé là beau
sari marché parce qu'ils sont prêts ou
cissé mais c'est ça mais après ce soir
d'eads le piler travail continu pis mais
la voix encore plus que star académie
j'ai l'impression parce que cet arrêt
qu'il y avait quand même quelque chose
de
on prend du monde six jeunes aussi plein
les mains dans une maison puis on lit
formes qui font avoir une personnalité
c'était comme une espèce de volley-ball
tamouls alors qu'est la voix je pense
qu'ils recherchent des personnalités
puis chercheur je les vois aussi évident
qu'à 17 star ac' émettant il sortait de
l'eau piller comme ok facture watts est
vrai que la rebelle toiture sacrée miss
est vrai que tu sentais le branding
tandis qu'à l'intérieur parce que j'ai
chuté la famille accompagnatrice le cpie
raison du manque encore non non c'était
pas terrible
c'est ce qu'a l'heure le monde écoute en
corner
serrano demi finale mais à moins qu'ils
sachent vraiment à poté équipe qu'est ce
que tu veux chanter ils vont choisir
pour toi mais c'est arrive le petit
monde fait elle seule la musique puis je
fais sur ce je m'envole où ils te
laissent à l'eiti que le croquer la voix
quand même te contrôler sur ta
proposition artistique complètement rien
contre eux non si je disais que les ti
l'aï dit oui inch'allah que les gens y
en a qui disent mais moi en effet je
suis d'accord avec toi qui t'y mets ton
renault le quelles sont les missions de
biche bien content pour lui dans leur
frustation métier
lolo à qui kohl métier cif en corse et
dans 5 10 à livarot prouver que c'est
madame aurait à le prouver qu'ils aient
pas juste la fille de temps après un
certain temps puis de travail et il est
conseillé de travailler c'est pas comme
toi j'ai fait ce film arrive sur
d'affaires de weck homme si brillant ne
dit qu'ils sont là pour rester
c'est incorrect le tir et j'aiderai que
c'est ça j'ai de la misère à me
farrington par rapport à ce type à je me
dis bon renault au kenya un show oui en
âge contemporain crise en fait mais puis
on dire non parce qu'elle leur oui on
sait qu'un exemple un exemple bien sûr
quand lui mais tu sais je me dis qu'est
ce qui fait que de gaulle à cette place
le dans un show de radio alors que les
gens qui étudient encore moins y en a
sûrement dit étudie pour ceux qui savent
leurs affaires depuis qu'ils ont un jeu
mais c'est comme une espèce d'affaires
de on profite du boxeur de ses sources
et sur certains la nuit c'est sûr et
certain
jusqu'à mi mai lors en dieu après s'il
veut dire de la merde à radio j'espère
que vous comprenez ce que je vais te
tuer on en parle c'est pour ça que je
pense que ce genre de gueule quand tu
sors tu traînes c'est 100 % pour ceux
les 100% pour avoir ce même chose mais
ton ex andré qui sont son show de télé
c'est 100% pour la visibilité que ça
donne maintenant si ce que tu fais tu es
bon pit et naturel
spie tu veux travailler vers ce
possiblement ça va continuer parce
qu'après ça mettons que ok le trend est
passé le monde ont découvert justement
fait nous la cour qui le haïssent
d'israël eux c'était pas le meilleur
animateur puis on va prendre quelqu'un
qui fait ce puis une autre date exacte
mais comme tu dis tu es quelqu'un qui
est à l'étudier mettons trois ans
jean-pierre 1
c'est quoi la technique à jonquière
ouais je pense ce puits puis qui sort de
la piste vraiment un bon communes 14 à
la nicolas où elle est oui lui c'est le
meilleur au monde
pis tu dis ben on va prendre vite c'est
au long terme ça c'est sûr qu'elle lui
mettant lui a gigolo ouellette je suis
comme si je savais ce qu'il pensait de
ce nom mais devait dans id
quand tu vois que c'est quelqu'un
finalement qui sort d'occupation double
puis kiki qui avait posté en tête du
tout fait pas nécessairement les
connaissances quand quelqu'un qui est
comme ça je m'en sors de ce milieu loeb
qui fait crise suscite un gain j'aurais
aimé savoir moi mais après c'est sans
aucun doute - mettant c'est comme si
quelqu'un sort d'occupation de plus de
volant roll back ispo volet non mais je
ne l'avais pas abandon mais qui a un
rôle dans quelque chose puis je me dis
ah bé tabarnak un témoin mettant ça fait
25 ans que je travaille fort pour faire
ça comme j'ai pas eu l'audace peut-être
d'aller à occupation double ou jeunes
mais en même temps après ce correct
parce que si je pense que ça en prendre
de toutes les sortes pour faire un monde
aussi pis c'est correct va toujours
n'avoir pu mais c'est vrai que ça peut
être peut être frustrant bien précieux
après ce mois à talent un engagement je
m'attriste
dans le fond ton parcours exact a
également assez bien pour quelqu'un qui
qui qui qui jamais fait ça de sa vie
peut arriver maintenant le même talent
et l'expérience l'expérience et le
talent possiblement mais l'expérience
d'après ce que prétend tout aussi des
gens qui ont pu étudier en théâtre
verser des gens qui dit fête ses 25 ans
d'expérience pour compenser métier et 1
go génie qui veut faire de la com qui
aimeraient dont ceux qui vont étudier la
dame qui s'adonne le petit conte versera
knockin acl ben va prendre à moi je veux
faire déranger le lit crossover de
métier à la limite je m'en contrefous
plus que comme on disait tantôt le désir
fame
- je pense que l'appareil les
influenceurs puis internet ya beaucoup
d'eux
je veux être connus que je veux montrer
que j'ai une belle vie puis que gérard
bouchard pgd bouvette main pique je suis
belle puis je maintiens que demande
or depuis que je suis beau piqué on
dirait que ça moi c'est ça qui me gausse
un peu plus parce que je me dis ben
c'est quoi le but puis ça en fait c'est
que je pense pas que ça me gosses c'est
que ça me fascine parce que j'ai jamais
compris sa fin le même pour jean les
vedettes genre rapide dans rue des gens
qui crypte qui arrache son linge comme
mais je comprends pas pas que je pense
qu'il ya quelque chose encore plus fou
avec internet pas je me dis c'est des
gens qui parlent majoritairement de
leurs maisons de leurs chiens de leur
choix de leurs affaires personnelles de
leurs sentiments
il faut que ce soit comme super g puis
que ce soit je suis pas sûr qu'on prenne
ce que je dis je comprends je pense que
rapidement le monde cette année là
dessus c'est j'ai dû monter même si
peut-être parfois peut-être résultat
c'est pas ce soja du monde ce que je
veux c'est delà de la pure philanthropie
moi j'ai le mécanisme pour justifier le
compresseur exactement je suis plus
d'accord avec ceux de dire que derrière
le désirent
je crois que fondamentalement les gens
qui font ce qu'ils sont bien en faire ce
qui est un désir de se montrer
puis de se faire voir et ça c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser mais que la
justification à ce c'est maintenant mais
j'arrête des gens je crois pas je crois
que ça je crois que c'est vraiment un
faible pourcentage qu'il est pro il doit
moins pourcentage de gens qui c'est moi
mettons c'est mon cas quand je suis
quand je parle plus vous allez dire
peut-être que je dis ça juste pour est
clé pour justifier mon comportement
mais quand je me dis mais dont je parle
de mon livre de recettes
oui c'est mercantile ou c'est quelque
chose que je veux oui mais j'ai
l'impression que dans ce jeu fait un
plus et je suis dans colonne des plus
dans mes méthodes et je pose une
question qui je veux régler quelque
chose dans ma tête c'était certes raté
sortie d'occupation double si tu avais
dit la sphère de journalisme gonzo puis
à un moment donné tu avais genre
quelques jours après avait poussé une
photo de maillot je rembobine beach
georges pas trop bien manier j'avais
commenté est-ce que c'est du journalisme
gonzo
mais dit il à ce prix mais ils me
détestent
alger - ben je sais pas je me rappelle
pas ça se peut à ce moment là j'étais
maladroit avec les commentaires le jeu
mais possible cession comprend cela dit
puisque c'était bien dans la taquinerie
mais je me demande justement qu'est ce
qui fait que
en sortant s'était dit ok mais tango je
le fais tu mets ton genre moi je te juge
tango qui étudient quotidien journal la
littérature et journalisme terre à
remédier à ça maintenant tu dis je fais
avec passion 2 pour l'expérience
je veux le vivre visage comprends parce
que moi j'ai dit tout le temps que
j'aimerais ça vivre cette expérience je
trouve fascinante et puis l'autre sort
puis qu'est-ce qui fait que te fait ok
maintenant le livre de recettes comprend
la végétation oui le plus aimé mettons
les maillots de bain non sortant s'était
tu le caches où tu t'es dit 100% de
montry ce sens pour 5 100 % l'argent
parce que quand tu vois occupation deux
des gens mais ton comme des gens comme
renault justement qui ont une job le
tipi que leur vie est commencé c'est pas
tout le monde qui est prêt à les
accusations double que ça fait que les
gens qui vont ce soit jacques des gens
qui sont soit aux études en deux emplois
dans ce genre de job que tu peux changer
moi dans mon cas c'est fini c'est ma
carte natation piges j'avais comme rien
d'autre qui s'en venait famous qui joue
à prendre ce camp tout en volant tu fais
pas tu fais deux cents pièces par
semaine fait qu'on s'entend que ça ne
paie pas un appart le petit voleur
sortent plus
moi je sortirai de la caisse j'ai pas de
job jeunes à part te payer g qu'est ce
qui s'en vient comment je fais pour
utiliser ce que je viens de faire le
sans retourner travailler 40 heures
parce que je suis retombé ya 40 ans je
peux pas continuer des projets je peux
créer des projets créatifs comme par
exemple le podcast est ce ici c'est le
livre de recettes suggère-t-on trail 40
hors jeu mais avec surtout dessous mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait tout ça pour
rien je refuse de penser je les fais
pour eux rien fait comment je fais pour
continuer les projets en faisant de
l'argent rapide facile impose de
maillots de bain en formule 2 100
piasses ça fait un mois de loyer pour un
post bac oui c'était 100% pour l'argent
puis j'en ai essayé d jamais s'affilier
gironde j'exprime on ne cite jamais
s'appuyer avec dédé brent ont endossé
peau
est ce que le fait très bien si vous le
faites de manière intelligente j'ai on
essaie on essaie mais pour répondre à ta
question c'était plus dans le dos était
pas riendeau c'était juste ça va être
une façon de faire de l'argent
je comprends le tir je comprends la
question sur le coup peut-être que je
les lis tes chez que tu venais de vivre
avons ainsi d'affaires avec adam hall
sur les dictionnaires des vedettes vois
ce que tu avais commenté lyon la
définition un spectacle qui s'était
appelé or la farde c64 sortait
d'occupation douce sas plus jeunes
s'embrassaient pu mais oui en effet
c'est baveux dans ce sens que ce thème 0
méchant puis moi ça me tue c'est le
souci je pense qu'elles forment à nice
tu fais quand je dis est il fou rire un
peu de parler comme tu vois là tu
m'écris la somme puis j'irai prime c'est
juste que tu t'es tellement bas lancer
dans quelque chose que je connais c'est
pau que j'évoque un code de conduite sur
comment répondre à quoi qu'est-ce qui
est qui qui est qu'ils instaurent la
pitié j'avais comme pas de report du
tout dans ce film est intéressant parce
qu'il ya peut-être de sauter 42
justement la fin de compte pas en parler
maintenant depuis avoir du fun sur
internet pickett et non au sérieux payé
peut-être une partie de ceux de
commettons ont fait des jo qui est les
gens le prennent mal pepsi prudents
parce qu'ils savent pas comment réagir
dans le sens que je sais pas mais c'est
intéressant quand même staff arles de
coin
mais ce n'est pas la personne c'est le
maintenant d'écrire n'importe quoi puis
on sélectionne jobs en personne tout le
cpo la bave dessus c'est une joke
c'est quoi c'est pour ça qu'on peut pour
ça qu'elle réseaux sociaux existe aussi
des moyens d'avoir des échanges qui dès
je pense de créer quelque chose de l'fun
avec sont aussi doubles dames où ça va
être quand même été sauf tout va changer
et catherine chicane score et moi dans
ma tête c'est pas une chicane jeter
comme c'est drôle si le monde après ceux
qui prennent ce au premier degré c'est
sur ce seul problème c'est surtout les
juristes donne le nom de mon team écrite
genre est vraiment une [ __ ] genre de
maison mes champs quand je fais mon
personnage des fluence heures alors que
met-on jeune homme personnes un certain
que c'est comme le diamant ce générique
le et super génériques soit marchetti
que tu prend de plein de monde que tu me
demandes de mise et même des fois le
genre faut juste un type de personne
c'est beaucoup de monde sur les réseaux
sociaux le qui a du monde qui m'envoient
chier tu mets ton elle manie j'avais
fait j'avais fait une imitation de
quelque chose
la personne m'avait envoyé chez vous
m'avez dit antique ou telle personne a
trouvé vraiment pas ça drôle que tu
limite celle quoi auquel personne je ne
sais même pas si qui cette personne le
nom
taghli gens prennent vraiment au sérieux
puis je pense que c'est karine ammann et
karin saint michel à m'avait écrit m
thiam avait dit il ya plein de monde qui
me disent que tu imites puis j'ai comme
et voyons karine je pense jamais vu thi
story j'ai aucune idée puis après c'est
vrai que j'allais voir le cdh est
récente
l'expression personnelle d'explication
si chapeautait mail
on sait par les pièges des comme je suis
désolé que tous les gens te disent eux
mais ce pourrait être 100% pas été comme
un kit parfait jeu contentant de cora ça
me fait rire mais en tout cas c'est vrai
que sa mère sandra raté puisque abeilles
cordiale après les gens sont comme ça là
les gens qui prennent la défense des
personnes qui suivent
ça sent vraiment qu'il ya de qu'elle dit
kai personnes qui leur demande de le
faire sinon puis ben salah des
conversations défaut avec du monde qui
m'écrivent way and scoot était vraiment
pas un bon exemple pour les jeunes
pillent
c'est vraiment peuls mais j'ai la
conversation avec ces gens là quand même
parce que je reçois mettant au contraire
sans message mettons pour un message
plein genre soit 100 de monde qui me
disent pas ça fait du bien un peu de
répit de prendre ça à la légère de voir
rigoler sur instagram peep a juste cité
se prendre au sérieux justement pas
quand les gens disent c'est vraiment pas
drôle c'est de l'intimidation je prends
le temps de répondre parce que je me
dise je voudrais pas que ce soit perçu
comme ce pic ce soit perçu comme la
méchanceté tpi de la haye à m
c'est vraiment possible c'est que c'est
cool de pouvoir s'entendre sur une forme
plus longue par rapport à dieu comme en
ce moment
saluant ce que je pense qu'il est
vraiment vraiment qu'ils vont comprendre
la patente mais c'est clair c'est un
drôle de s'éteindre l'époque dans lequel
on vit ici spécial ces critiques la
motte à consommer safari complètement je
regarde tout ça c'est ce que je dis moi
c'est quand les gens disent
tailler les influenceurs t engages comme
ok mais pas du tout facile c'est un
phénomène qui me fascine complètement
qui je dois me taper pleine affaire bien
noté videmment que comme aux mondiaux
cet accouchement pourquoi j'ai coûté 15
minutes d'une rupture en live c'est
pourquoi j'ai regardé ça mais je les
regarde et je pense que c'est important
de pas être comme nos parents qui
étaient communes aux grands-parents qui
était comme moi j'aimais mieux selon
l'auteur de la télé en noir et blanc
comme pour manille et bombay puis
comprendre les nouveaux médias puis les
nouveaux médiums mais faction consomme
énormément le genre je suis une poule b
tout là-dessus
non mais parce que j à qui tu veux pas
mais ton je suis comédienne mon envie
puisque ce qui fait que j'aime jouer
c'est que ça mais ça me donne une
fenêtre sur des vies que je connais pas
ouais mais tamoul indépendant vis je
marche le puis je regardais fois travers
les fenêtres du monde quand ils sauront
piquer leur lumière est allumée ouvrir
ce comme un brin nostalgique parce que
je me dis je connaîtrai jamais cette
ville je connais pas ces gens ne
connaissent jamais je n'ai jamais eu
j'aurais jamais cette maison le jeu de
jouer pour moi c'est un peu une fenêtre
sur des univers que je connais pas puis
qui me permettent d'explorer les trucs
de faire connaître ces gens là ces
personnages
admettons mon personnage d'influenceurs
bellevue pour c'est pour moi une manière
de comprendre que d'essayer de
comprendre je pense que c'est pour ça
que ça existe dès lors la télé la
communication en général tu es ok oui je
pense que c'est plus ceux plus une
affaire de compréhension que de
ridiculiser du monde puis des puits dans
le c'est vraiment intéressant quand tu
dis que tu prends le soin et la fuite
ce qu'est ce que ça vaut vie vous avoue
que sa présence si le désir de vouloir
te glisser dans la peau de quelqu'un de
puissant j'imagine que dans ton métier
d'actrice et
c'est un plan sexe comme ça que tu tôt
par par exemple admettons compte amène
un personnage je pense complètement
autre chose et on compte amène un
personnage est ce que tu t'es c'est de
vraiment comprendre son univers pour
pour apprécier entré dans sa vie dans sa
danse on est dans son monde mais je
pense que c'est ce que j'aime c'est
qu'il phone pour moi je pense de
d'essayer en tout cas de donner une
psychologie a disposé à faire des genres
j'aime bien me sentir la personne c'est
comme si peu dans mes billets un peu en
quelque sorte mais pour moi c'est pas
comme métaphysique où ce projet c'est
plus une affaire de on va essayer de
raconter une histoire
mettons un film on va essayer de
raconter cette histoire là du mieux
qu'on peut
puis en imitant d'une certaine manière
certaines personnes loin en essayant de
s'approprier leur vie de s'approprier
ça fait du bien des fois parce que je
pense que pour être acteur pas que ça
peut prendre plus et de l'empathie
1 parce que je veux pas des fois tu dis
je pourrai juger cette personne là mais
le faut je la joue comme on l'a compris
que je comprenne ouais ok je pense que
si ce qui montre que c'est ce que j'aime
de ce métier qui de ceux de ce médium le
de communication ont reçu le 2 jours ne
tournait pas de casque et rose marie
peyrot je la connais mais oui puis on a
fait pipi ensemble récemment on a fait
six pieds avec tfou le film parce que
moi c'était plus lent quelqu'un m'a
entendu une personne qui a toutefois
celle-ci et mouchoirs défi qu'avait dit
que souvent en tout cas bref ces points
ouais mais en l'état les examens sur ce
terrain là où justement pis mousset qui
m'impressionne le plus le jabra me
répéter mais c'est pas grave le monde y
ce qui me gêne le plus c'est d'être
capable de se glisser dans la peau de
quelqu'un tu sais pas ce qu'on lui dit
exactement presque mot pour mot ce que
j'ai dit c'est que chacun ne deviez
travers nos yeux trouver ma propre
expérience renault propre bagage qui
fait qu'on voit le monde travaille
vraiment un prisme très classe très
pareil de ski et la ville
il y est d'être un acteur c'est vraiment
acquis et bombay de cette personne le
quai avec qui j'ai pris en commun
peut-être tous posent des fois t'es
comprendre à ces deux semaines dans ses
souliers sais de quoi tu sais vraiment
c'est puisque le gicl et la psychologie
célèbre c'est justement de l'empathie
est capable de d2 pour ça c'est
impressionnant je trouve mais ses
capacités
je pense qu'on le tout ce système et on
on appelle ce jouet on est comme on joue
mais quand on est petit on le tout cette
capacité le t on un petit puis on ne
nous donne en billons où on s'invente un
jeu on est les cowboys les un dîner et
comme on quand on est jeune on eu toute
cette capacité la semaine dans la peau
de monde qu'on connaît pas ou des
personnages qu'on connaît pas parce
qu'on mimiques parce qu'on regarde des
films parce qu'on regarde des décennies
parce qu'on est maintenant moi je me
rappelle on jouer à pokémon le terrain
ouais puis on
je pense qu'en
on perd à mener cette réflexion et de
jouer mais je pense que c'est ea sein de
le faire pipi c'est si comme
thérapeutique je pense viennent ouais
mais tu y seras moins des fois il faut
que j'arrête de penser puis dans le
cliché de l'artiste torturé vous pouvez
je pense qu'il existe pour une raison
parce qu'il m'a dit je sais pas parce
que les poches des artistes de torturer
mais vraiment vraiment un peu ce que je
pense qu'il ya des gens qui sont
torturés puis qui ont pas la chance de
l'exprimer comme étant le peintre ou un
routeur wi réalisateurs où je pense que
ça c'est 5 pour les gens de jouer puis
de fabrique road qui est ce pour ça que
l'or est important je pense vraiment moi
je me rappelle quand j'étais petit
rappel quand j'étais jeune à l'âge d'un
enfant je passais des heures et des
heures dans la piscine chez nous moi je
pensais du temps aussi dans piscine
pochy nommé l'été je passais des heures
et des heures et des ordres qui signent
chez nous elle a joué un rôle limité un
guerrier grec
on va t'en rappelles puis je me faisais
des histoires complètes je passais des
heures dans ma piscine tout seul à
tourner auront pu la faire comme si la
battait dit
j'ai arrêté de faire ce sale naturel
pour moi le genre qui je parlais dans
l'eau le ti j'étais vraiment dans une
savane est naturel pour moi plus j'ai
complètement arrêté de faire simple le
depuis quelques mois je recommence à
jouer à donjons dragons avec ce n'est
pas demain l'heure j'essaie de me
remettre dans peau d'un personnage mais
quand l'iss j'ai perdu ce que je dis tu
joue le personnage pense à woippy
c'est vraiment le fun tissu attends je
te dis avec la voix que j'ai le laisser
partir et laisser partir princesse
vénaux ça sonne bizarre l'été qui va
tomber c'est sûr je lisais encore cette
voie là puis je pense que je suis partie
retraçant sénat je pense pas que je suis
prêt à le faire mais bon ami génie parce
que allemagne on se faisait quand on est
genre à l'école puis on se faisait comme
l'or a déniaisé lepileur elle soit dans
le vraiment on n'a jamais rêvé arrête
d'inventer des histoires arrête de
mentir and they come on se fait
tellement durand m'a dit d'arrêter
question a consisté comme brise et
manipule en tant qu'adulte sur essaie de
le feuilleter comme h par jenny pourquoi
je ferais ce monde génère 4 quand je
fais ça mais c'est juste pourquoi sujet
un effort selon ce fait tellement et
mettre dans des moules ton caisse mais
pour ce qui est aussi gym et on lime les
influenceurs chemin qui révèle leur vie
mais tombe devant la caméra
seulement il ya quelque chose qui
m'intéresse là dedans parce
qu'évidemment je me dis waouh en ayant
comme pote filtre non plus tu es une
piste assez cassé quand même mais c'est
comme ça prend quand même du golfe fois
et définitivement définitivement de deux
mètres de haut vol à nu un nu
complètement devant du monde c'est parce
qu'il joue un personnage c'est pas toi
tu peux tu tues tu protèges carrément
mthatha ce qui est proche de toile dans
l'intimité du protéine qui joue un
personnage qui camoufle complément c'est
exact alors que
directs indirects dans personnes qui
étaient souvent d'entrée sécurité dans
tes problèmes dans tes troublante et
petits n'empêche que ça à quelqu'un qui
voit sur le jeu fait à l'accord l'avocat
dit d'avocats c'est un peu un rôle de
grande soeur des grands frères cissé
l'impression qu'ils étaient vite on dit
lisant la dope les différents comme ceux
seppi tiens qui part de leurs
difficultés c'est pô juste d'achever une
crise de panique à l'annoncé sympathique
et un million de personnes par million
métier beaucoup de personnes que je
supporte seul tu dis quelque chose de
gai mais quelque chose de bien parlé
tantôt des rôles je pense que c'est un
rôle qui m'est qui est nécessaire mais
en même temps je me dis le temps que ces
jeunes le passe à regarder ça et parce
qu'on parle beaucoup de l'isolément jeux
vidéo pc il ya beaucoup de solitude
je pense que ça quand même ça peut
croque rusé safar lieu de voir que mes
temps de passer son temps à avoir
l'impression que ta grande soeur être
parle de manière impersonnelle devant
une cam - tenus d'en parler avec
quelqu'un pour vrai oui ça peut aider
moi je suis sûr que tu sors et certaine
que ça doit aider du monde mais quand
comme je disais moins la sphère de
pas faire par exemple de chirurgie est
d'avoir un discours qui étrenne oui j'ai
le droit d'être moi même je dois être
moi même je me suis fait refaire les
seins en effet complètement complètement
vrai sauf que là près de faire une vidéo
python public c'est des filles de 14 18
ans qui cherche depuis que son pote
trouver comme comme lt qui sont pas une
fin août et je pense que ça peut
mettre des idées dans la presse pas
grave parce que on n'en sont censées
mettre des idées dans tête de plaine
manière sûre que le sais juste que quand
c'est quelqu'un qui est l'impression que
c'est un grand oeuvre qui dit ok on va
aller faire un point qu'on va les genres
chi genre oui j'ai vite fait comme à mon
grand frère ichi dans le parking jg
c'est super cool ou si je vais faire
comme nous on avait déjà cassé jaccar
jackass j'imagine que c'était moins
c'était moins viscéral que j'imagine que
le pourcentage de personnes qui
considérait jackass au sérieux était
plus bock le nom des personnes qui
considèrent ces jal au sérieux et c'est
finalement qu'il prenait un panier il y
en a qu il faisait de son mariage le
jour où on a écouté depuis moins de six
mois le 2 je n'avais jamais vu en ligue
au stade où je pense que tu es sur
netflix le principe quand on regarde ces
drôles de civils
certains moi je sais que j'ai vu style
quand ben ahmad gibril ce nom c'est
sûrement de ce que moi les trois pour
ceux et celles qui les gens
l'accueillent copier coller
comme si la scène hyper des influences
de jackass
de toute évidence jean even ce qui fait
des faits des entrevues qui s'appellera
antoine sur youtube le whisky malaisie
puis il l'a fait avec steve optionnel de
poulet vega estivaux et vegan
demande me pose cette question la stivo
dit qu'est ce que tu penses maintenant
des preuves sur internet parce qu'ils
disent objets tier les les premiers à
faire seul pivot est dit nous on n'a
jamais rien fait qui pouvait créer du
tort à quelqu'un dont on n'a jamais fait
une pointe qui pouvait créer du tort à
quelqu'un d'autre mais jouissant
peut-être d'un club le même sillon du
cygne et c'est peut-être dans gangs
laitiers mais qui peut mettre en risque
la job de quelqu'un qui peut exposer
quelqu'un qui est le faux sur le cola
qui sort des p o beaudoin
il fait ce qu'il veut lui fait ce qu'il
veut notamment
mais même sans son consentement un
chauffeur de taxi qui ne fait que sa job
ce moi je loge est un réel problème avec
pays a beaucoup d'affinités mettons à
l'émission huissier mais c'est quand
même langue d'une certaine manière dans
le sens qu'est il y en a plein de choses
comme cela dit je veux dire hé hé oui on
peut inventer seul dans le sens qu'il ya
tellement de choix mettant aux states ou
si comme arrestations musclées pilleurs
exact complètement sûr qu'après les gens
ils disent mais ton chemin dans marde
toi je vais être payés ou soit gens sont
chauds noir outils comme oui après leur
face et bar il ya quand même quelque
chose de vicieux dans notre désir de
voir on est dedans mardi déjà dispo pour
une affaire de p&o ça fait l'homme
d'état ce crime ça brise et l'internet
le genre comment les gens aiment solide
les situations et les gens isigny plus
que d'autres choses mais moi j'ai vu
beaucoup d'influencé par les comptes lui
jeter comme huawei en faisant cela c'est
la fin du monde vos amis en france on
vous lit comme ça non mais moi
honnêtement
je veux le mettre en dessous de base
avec complètement impunément pillet est
connu d'accord je suis d'accord avec ce
fait quelque chose comme ce j'espère
qu'on va me colle et puis j'espère que
tout le monde qui fait un métier sur
internet vont encore lille
c'est sur le site reçoit problème aussi
c'est jean belotti c'est vraiment elle
était ce des situations comme celle
justice comme si lula la perle arrêté de
tourner parce que le monsieur x factor
mais que je te crois puis j'espère que
tu as de la première à me coller je fais
quelque chose comme si parce que moi le
tchèque mauvais à chaque fois mais ça
pour toi comme tu veux mais tu tues tu
vas pas filmée du monde contre leur gré
qui ont rien fait
ton rien demandé que tout ce qu'ils font
c'est vouloir être payer pour un service
qu'ils ont rendue pour le ridiculiser y
fait sa job je trouve ça un énorme
manque de jugement piges
mais toi tu trouves tu que moi même
étant de thé le top 10 des gens qui
auraient demandé de ce team étant
justement là nouveau trend de femmes
enceintes les jambes et checkpoint de
donner la vie a mis de l'avant sa
grossesse pitt et comme tu dis pas qu
deux farceurs des photos de bébé de 10
mai tombait de plus de la naissance du
bébé
keller vidéo de huit vélos puis des
nanas comme ceux de l'abbaye rien
demandé non correctes oil jules est le
même
le même concept m'asseoir un blog avec
halo 4 enfants cinq ans puis à
documenter ce puits se donner un âge où
est-ce qu'elle allait arrêter pour ses
enfants les nomme jamais par leur nom
personne ne connaît leurs noms personne
si c'est quoi documente la maternité on
les voit les enfants mais à l'omi un âge
qui éventuellement l arrêter si l'enfant
n'était pas d'accord a continué aucun
d'eux c'est normal que tu prennes
décisif en détiendra y demande à rien
n'existe qui répond de tifa quittera les
meilleures décisions tu penses
la presse est ce que c'est une bonne
décision le sinistre est questionnable
non mais si c'est mais ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'elle pas l'oeuvre par
lippi deux chauffeurs de taxi qui a rien
demandé je commets les réseaux sociaux
maintenant explique beaucoup de choses
- avec des gens qui ont des jeunes qui
ont rien à voir mais quand je pense aux
août chamand trop de pays ou blonds doté
de plusieurs influences ans et la
grammaire mais mettez des jantes de les
publier que le thé comme est et je veux
que ça implique beaucoup de monde quand
ta carrière c'est de montrer ta vie
c'est pis ceux ci est aussi à prendre en
considération je suis là mais encore une
fois tous ces gens là tu es souvent les
gens qui sont proches de toi sont au
courant de ces gens n'ont rien demandé
mais au moins y ont peut-être accepter
le fond et moi mettons cash prennent
story pique ma soeur est dedans c'est
que j'entraîne ne prendre que dans tout
ce que ça implique t il mettant la
blonde adamou je pense qu'elle voulait
rien savoir mais pas du tout on la voit
poule non mais là tranquillement tête et
commence à accepter mais c'est au début
on l'a jamais vu ce qui fait que tu aies
un moyen d où ça m'intéresse pas du tout
paquet
le métier des affaires comme il y avait
une mannequin qu'elle ait pris une photo
d'une femme nue dans un gym dans le
vestiaire je le dis madame de son prénom
selphy la vente en arrière betty c'était
vraiment pour qu'on la voit piste est
comme genre quinten 6 10 mai à la salle
alors ça jupp heynckes est méchant c'est
prendre fois toute personne nuit sans
son consentement dans un vestiaire pour
ça que maintenant ils écrivent dans les
gyms dans les vestiaires j'ai voté de
talent eu aucun sens qui justement est
elle appréciée
ah ça non mais moi je suis vraiment pas
de même le suis pas quelqu'un comme
sauter prouver à tout le monde que tu es
quelqu'un comme ceux que tu es quelqu'un
comme ça être exposé car disait tantôt c
c'est plate mais qui quand tu es
quelqu'un un peu coco justement les gens
finissent par sa grande 46 fayed et
cultive un petit peu ton esprit critique
ton intelligence ton jugement
on est tous les coucous de quelqu un qu
apple que je trouve qu ils doivent me
trouvais coco le titre comme on est tout
et après qui après le côté carrément
méchant puis tu fais une affaire de même
et comme la fille qui s'appelait ans
elias vite [ __ ] belle bagarre de
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de sites
internet que sa part qui s'appelle m
un maire de grasse appel mais c'est tout
du monde que leur faute au thunder ou
grinder et eux devant le monument aux
morts à berlin mais son genre c'est
comme des foules belles photos mais
clairement passé les gens savent pas ce
qu on sait seul à faire ce que j'ai vu
le travail d'un photographe qui
prenaient des vieillissements darchy la
position avec les centres et la selphy
aujourd'hui jarre la scène davant dans
le tas ces frappes a baissé ça c'est que
les gens aussi
outre les gens qui travaillent là dedans
c'est que ce que ça amène aussi c'est
que les gens sont de plus en plus portés
à le faire même si spoiler métier même
s'il est jeune et on 12 impossible celle
fip sealife cij en fin d'épreuve pour
c'est normal parce qu'ils grandissent
avec ça c'est leur malheur moyen de
crémant de devenir cool parce que là
c'est super cool être comme ceux puis le
problème c'est que le problème comme si
je savais c'était quoi m
mais tendent à des places comme of the
beach dans une concentration ou dans les
hauts lieux d'écouté la faire un tour
puis de s'informer des de s'éduquer sur
l'histoire de svg puis sur les camps de
concentration mais on
je mets tout là dedans non parce que je
préfère des services souvent on veut
montrer qu'on est la place de preuves du
de vraiment utiliser le moment pour être
le ouais ouais sim et on est en voyage
puis souvent ça va être dur mais on sent
une photo alain à l'enquêté comète et
enfin king voyage jusqu'à prendre un
break mais je le fais moi aussi pour ce
que c'est on le fait tous ces mets ont
kg n'empêche pas l'autre parce que tu
prends une photo que tu profites pas du
moment pas parce que mon par mme amara
qu'on ne sait pas on part c'est simon et
mon beau-frère et me raconter une
histoire et un un voyage je m'habitue ou
peut-être au colorado entre que dans un
endroit où est ce qu'ils signaient la
neige
plug & tech il est sûr bord sont un sur
une terrasse ou sur un bar peu importe
n'avait plus revu par ses deux filles
qui était jean rabier que les feuilles
sont mis à côté d'une rampe comme une
vue derrière juste d'europe et le genre
en maillot de bain les photos comme nous
on a fait en fait exactement fait
exactement ce exact
c'est de l'oeil de l'été sinon qu'
aucune corps et ses couettes
ils voient ça me fait juste ce truc
c'est qu'on a fait cette saison l'a
clairement fait pipi clar mais si bien
moins d je vois des photos comme ceux ci
comme pourquoi c'est encore un peu la
question de faire le coq si jamais fait
et mettons le prends des photos en
maillot de bain sur le sol dont la boîte
où le talent c'est quoi l'hôte africa
mix met des fruits c'est autant le jeudi
c'est comme bio sort je pense j'en ai vu
cache dans les andes à l'an dernier moi
je comme we serve comme quatre
organismes et des fruits dans le soir à
place est un sou un sou est chouette
bien un coup d'état être ni boule un
string avec deux ânes à ne pas prendre
une part restant gamme de genres de
quelqu'un qui veut embêter georges
charme évident j'ai quelqu'un qui bouge
à meaux salifou kébé ça c'est moi pas tu
aspirateur ça devient maman et montmagny
ça finira par tomber dans une seule
affaire de legends le ferai après
[Musique]
certains jeunes qui pose son inspirateur
g-strings merci c'est la nouvelle a tout
filmé temps qu'ils mangent rapide
puissant comme c'est un jour je mange
pape sy djamil si on commence donc on
mangeait plus trop aux hôpitaux comme si
moi c'est ainsi
il ya des affaires des fois que reste
craignez-vous pas les faits mais j'ai
quand même parce que tu resteras 344
jours
la photo est posté avec les grosses
boules
mais hier la bande à peu compris c'est
jack mais y en a plein qui mixe des
diggers entre autres un gode mon second
dans la [ __ ] je leur fais des
photos sans poser de questions j'aurais
cliquer sur le nom dit m c'est fou ça
quand même que les gens aient peur mais
en même temps je comprends
sauf que ça en dit long le rue les gens
de cork et les gens sont habitués de
voir sur les réseaux sociaux puis le
genre de modifications complètement pour
vrai ça a pris un second alors c'est
facile je me savais les facebook
maintenant ça me fascine chez des amis
qu'ils ont sur leur selle puisque hommes
même si je peux comprendre après que les
couleurs sont plus belle il ya des
fuites et puis en même temps on en
parlait autrefois aussi terme et on est
gros boutons affronter tu prends une
photo parce que le set up et naïve tout
est cool et on est gros bouton parce que
tu sais que tu l'auras pull lèves tu
l'avais pas la veille tu leur parles en
suisse et de l'enlever est pas obligé de
l'envié mais ce qu est ce que tu te
l'enlever battle droit mettons à sa
droite tout le temps son voeu exaucé
leaf est désormais on négocie les mains
qui se maquillent fact et jeudi entre
maquiller un bouton pile faith tournée
jeudi
le problème c'est là que ça devient plus
vicieux parce que piquants plus ton
message
j'ai vu le turenne d'être authentique en
disant que tu utilises based in a way
that she is shown that i can't actuelle
est dans le mensonge laissez pas noir ou
blanc
en fait c'est noble à ce genre mans pour
moi on de ti mé agressés d'entrée de jeu
mme ampe au moins cinq méthodes de
vendre un produit auquel tu crois peut
maintenant j'attends la nouvelle crème
et déjà comment tu peux savoir si c'est
vrai ou pas qu'est ce qu'est la personne
dit moi-même- défauts de l'autre fois je
me rappelais plus qui je tombe dessus
comme sur ma page d'accueil une fille
que j'avais jamais vu puis qui parlait
d'un sérum me rappelle pas c'est quoi la
marque on sacralise puis apparaît nue au
sérum puis elle avait foule une belle
pour jeter comme wow oh mon dieu j'ai
moi aussi je veux c sérums ouvriers puis
shalit chéquier à pharmacie puis sté
genre 215 kg astrium au québec j'étais
en plus si je sais pas si en bout le
site web apple à htc le flou entre
la réalité basse pile ce qui fait la
ligne est parfois mince parce que tu
aimais tant le t2 fils que simon ya vu
un bikini de la minul pas six mais
vraiment il tourné une pub de quelque
chose
cavenne cloud piste est clair que cette
époque une pure perte
johnson avait un deal ça n'aurait rien
dit mais là c'est les réseaux sociaux
tout pendant ton propre nom mais c'est
peut-être même une pub non plus je
demande clairement sur mon point faible
c'est pas grave non plus tu fais ce que
tu veux mais tu y mets toi comme jeter
dans un bar au mexique l'autre fois puis
justement eu deux filles qui rendent
starchyk se foutent bien habillé y
rentrer dans le bar testé comme un bord
trendy le genre et instagram à bhl qui
lui nous on est là depuis un moment puis
les filles rentrent dans le bar elle
s'assoit au bar et commande rien est
prêt à fond le photoshoot
non entrés en jeu des photos check check
sa demande aux gens de prendre des
photos tout ce qui expose jusqu'au mais
c'est vrai que ça fait des belles photos
mais à quoi ça sert
c'est la réponse va plus loin que juste
admettons que ces personnes là il ya
deux voix deux enfants 6-6 2/1 c'est ton
travail où tu veux que ça devienne ton
travail tu n'as pas le choix de prendre
de créer du contenu parce que c'est le
mot qu'on utilise de créer du contenu
pour entretenir ce pour que les stars
continuent à être bonnes pour qu'un pied
pour que ton travail ou ton potentiel
travaillent puissent en bénéficier avec
admettons ses deux fils sont dits
inquiets aujourd'hui on travaille quand
renoncement mode travail création de
contenu on va aller en sport là on prend
des photos chaudes attention voilà telle
place on prend des photos chaudes on va
t'elle place aux enfers du contenu pour
éventuellement se soit on travaille
c'est fake ce mois je porte pas
nécessairement de jugement parce qu'il
faut prendre au moins j'aurai su le dire
j'ai pris un verre c'est la pression
c'est qu'elle succombe aux dons parce
que moi et beaucoup de monde mais ton
j'ai une espèce de crise pendant au shag
au point où est ce qu'ils on voyait des
photos de monde qui se prenant ses deux
filles qui dirait vraiment un bon show
par exemple de national je me disais
chèque et ça représente aller un
événement sur la terrasse d'une affaire
vip ou est-ce qu'il ya plein d'autres
mondes fond d'histoire ou est ce que tu
fais ta story tu les coûts de paul
chollet têtu l'écoutent pas à 6,6 et à
jobs probablement tu t'écoutes paul
chose tu l'écoutés coûte 2 tone study
qui se trame à rebours chop chop écoutez
c'est ce que je dis c'est une fois une
faute et si c est vraiment un bon bol
c'est un beau bâtiment personnes le
titan en transhumance avant un beau but
mais ils ont une autre vision de la
création de contenu ou quoi ou justement
du monde qui veulent juste
donner l'impression d'avoir d'être allé
à ce bord là parce que c'est un bar cool
moi mais entre les deux pays et votre
temps entre les deux c'est quand y'en a
qui font juste vouloir un faire paraître
de leur vie et les autres qui veulent
entretenir leur plateforme en fait là
évidemment quand anti-tabacs forme tu
m'en pose c'est la base
c'est le numéro un mélo de l'autre
aspect c'est de dire justement quelqu'un
qui sait pas sa job qui est pas besoin
de faire ce que les lans bar le pour
dire qu'ils sont doléances bord là pour
montrer au monde une photo hier soir là
c'est plus problématique selon - en même
temps mettons pas ce que tu dis si
mathis et la job l'agencé de la job en
effet de créer du contenu et puis c'est
sûr que qu'est-ce qui débute et
promettant à contre eux qu'est ce qui
définit mettant la science dans ces
filles là qu'ils veulent
brenda leur iphone leur live si tu en
veux mais mettant en péril a qui veulent
gagner leur vie puis peut-être
éventuellement justement c'est à la
portée de tout le monde ici par chi-x ou
bats en fait ceux qui rêvent de venir
mais les gars moi eux qui rêvent de
devenir ce ça penche dans l'autre côté
hockey de dire de dire tu aspires à sauf
qu'il faut que tu prennes les moyens
pour tout en le maintenant j'avais
besoin de tout le monde un peu tout le
monde mais j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui aspirent à ce
devrait possiblement fait que j'imagine
que j'imagine que tu es tu restes dans
la vérité mais c'est que tu aspires à
quoi en fait c'est sur la fin des
qualifications parce que le chiffre à
100 mais quand on tapait dans un chiffre
je pense inspira un chef de ford aux usa
un chiffre de pied éventuellement ça se
transforme en quelque chose d'autre plus
tu vois tu dire j'aimerais survivants
voyage si ça c'est comme da c'est comme
de plus je réfléchis
c'est comme si tout le monde avait le
goût dans le fond d'une vie
qui savent qui comme un peu dans
l'incertitude 2 0 qui pour une raison x
j'ai le goût d'avoir beaucoup de
followers pour
avoir des idées produits pour aller en
voyage mais vous comprenez ce que je
dise quelque chose de taxer pourquoi tu
choisis pour une autre une autre chose
ce que gilles a des fois d'un coup trop
petit un médecin non mais non mais dites
comprend six morts mettons que le goût
de faire une différence dans le monde
tu peux étudier en politique tu peux
aller 30 et ratures tu peux être
et qu'est ce qui fait que le la sphère
de followers
je sais pas obligés comme quelque chose
qui marche qui sera par exemple plus tôt
plutôt d'un flux ans plus tôt d'un
auditoire plus de chances de toucher
deux mots puis d'avoir message qui
positif
moi j'étais naïve une plus ma blonde
c'est son objectif de périère tout son
processus de prendre des photos en
bikini de d'acted activement poster de
d'entretenir ces réseaux sociaux de
continuer à augmenter son nombre
d'abonnés derrière tout ça you'll l'envi
de cannes à voir faire un caca va
vouloir faire passer un message pour une
cause pour laquelle accroît pauvres et
ça va rejoindre plaisamment
elle s'est activement sur la raison
principale quand même classe que tout ce
que vous faites par elle ou s'il va
tourner beaucoup beaucoup autour des son
engagement et jack axle voitre je le
vois mettons ce qui se comprend mais on
dirait que spock la même pour tout le
monde
j'ai pas l'impression effectivement mais
après est-ce que l'unafam x peu moins
bien ou mieux ou juste et des fois ça je
pensais que c'est la question que je me
pose le plus apam et en faire une
différence
c'est quoi la finalité de tunis - est-ce
que je pense pas que c'est avoir des
followers pour avoir des produits de
faire des voyages je pense que c'est un
beau défi rouge mais c'est pas un peu
triste patrice mais dans le sens qu'il
n'y a pas un peu de solitude là dedans
pinède tous que des deux bâtiments petit
moi mettons pas mon téléphone ou ma
batterie accrue bientôt prends mon
téléphone puis positifs à des stéroïdes
ce ça m'angoisse ça me procure aucun
plaisir hein j'ai pas l'impression que
pu m'exprimer puis 15 ans une plateforme
à ce que je peux et je pète artistes et
créatif
ça fait juste mango sujet pourtant
plaisir je poste un peu pour pour la
forme le produit remettra sans plus lcd
delta betriu qui venu ici qui joue orc
faudra fermer comme philippe autant
d'aptitudes sociales bt et peu importe
si cela m'était parce que la lutte car
il est aussi mais parce que dit elle
même qu'elle ait commencé à être les
réseaux sociaux a posté les crédits
caption ce cas elle s'est sentie
c'est ma super sympa que je mets ma
cible quand j'en ai posté puis je pense
que non plus alors célébrer cela fait
vraiment du bien se moquer de moi que ce
qu'ils font vraiment solidité les james
idée guillaume nadeau demetriou
j'aimerais ça fait vraiment du bien le
poète une si grosse angoisse
sinon santé mentale c'est fou imagine
j'imagine que ça leur procure du bien y
en a pour qui sonne le look blanc
devrait vraiment si c'est exact mais
d'enquêter ça fait très big brother ça
fait très genre dans 20 ans on sortirait
plus de chez nous on va être en réalité
virtuelle permettre comme salut ça va
[ __ ] on sera livrés net épicerie puis
ça serait quand même coup ses yeux
d'enfant celui avec samba et jeux vidéo
il y en a qui s'en plaindront dragons
comme mais ouais je comprends et où je
comprends parce que mettant moi je
m'étends dans les films dans les livres
on trouve tout une manière de s'évader
je vais arrêter puis ça c'est vrai que
ça peut être un vrai que ça peut être si
c'est ce qui leur fait bien mais si
c'est ce qu'ils équilibrent drive
j'avoue que c'était un bowling sur le
but c'est d'être rup de son petit
bonhomme de chemin dans la vie c'est que
la télé est un mot de la fin merci pour
sa diction et nuancé
voilà mes gamins vraiment c'est une
quelque chose qu'on mérite réflexion
oui exact en tant que société on se doit
de penser à ça on se doit de réfléchir
sur l'impact que ça lui la place qu'on
doit lui accorder qui est définitivement
s est pas une conversation qui perdure
non je pense que c'est le en bout de
ligne ou s'il faut qu'on se parle aussi
sur les décisions c'est notre ville
maintenant le pis si ce vraiment on
prend ça au sérieux puisque c'est un
travail qui pensent qu'il faut qu'on
garde le dialogue ouvert place pour
féliciter capables de se parler pour
être capables de se parler puis il faut
être capable de loin des communes qui
pour vrai pas juste genre derrière notre
fierté
mais tout laisse que tu le fais mais ton
eau du team attendait youtuber que tu
sais que les autres mettront thème pas
vraiment c'était déjà six et ces
personnes ben non parce que moi je te
parlais pas cité de noms mais c'est que
j'ai pas d'intérêt aussi dans le sens
que moi c'est une blague
rexie après le les gens aiment pomy
blague zschokke ya plein de monde qui
aime pas les blagues de mac world puis
s'assoit près que je tape tout le monde
était comme vu que c'est pas vers caen
vers quelqu'un si vraiment limité
quelqu'un le mettons que mon personnage
c'était un une des filles tv
mais en effet je me trouverai horrible
déjà par mois je serai pas ce qui me
j'aimerais en métier je n'ai pas de
discussions à voir avec personne parce
que c'est un personnage c'est comme le
bye bye les créateurs du bye bye appel
pour chaque mois et non pas qu'ils moi
je sens pas que j'ai besoin d'avoir une
discussion
une discussion avec qui que ce soit le
type il y en a 6 et ceux qui m'aiment
pas me suis comme un écrivez moi si vous
m'aimez obs en fait ce qui est en boucle
et aussi si quelqu'un a quelque chose à
me dire je suis très ouverte à la
discussion le juste que jamais personne
n'a rien dit non plus vu comme kiki même
pas qui m'aime je ne sais pas c'est
juste pour moi c'est vraiment de
l'humour puisque manière de m'exprimer
aussi fac
et merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]